and what's the latest update you can
give us on the evacuation of British
Nationals from Sudan well so far so good
it's going very smoothly
we've had about 300 out today four
flights there's no Log Jam at the
airport the message to the British
Nationals who want to leave is come to
the airport there's no great backlog no
great congestion and we're taking people
out in a steady Manner and we want them
all to come if they want to leave and as
you know we are urging them to do so if
they if they are eligible they should
come as soon as they can you say it's
gone smoothly and some people are saying
they've been stranded there's been
others saying there's been Anarchy
there's been violence that there should
have been escorts to help people get to
the airport safely how can you say it's
come smoothly well I mean in terms of
getting to the airport we adopted
exactly the same route as the Germans
did the Germans told people they needed
to get themselves to the airport and
then they would be taken out and we've
done exactly the same thing and people
have been coming to the airport and as I
say 300 to today there's there's a small
queue but not a large queue the Border
Force are processing people it's all
going relatively smoothly I mean there
are
and in these sort of situations uh that
the news isn't always accurate but what
I can tell you for certain tonight is
that about 300 people have already come
out will be more I think by the end of
the day and four flights have left
you say that people should continue to
come to the airport are you prepared to
stay until everyone who wants to get
there has managed to reach it we are ABS
we are absolutely in the hands of the
ceasefire so far more or less this
ceasefire has held this is the second
day of a three-day ceasefire we are
doing everything we can to make sure
it's prolonged and on The Wider stage
too trying to negotiate for a longer
ceasefire because if the combatants
don't lay down their arms and return to
Barracks there is going to be a
humanitarian catastrophe in Sudan but as
far as the British citizens are
concerned we are getting them out
there's a steady flow if you want to go
please come to the airport did you views
after the evacuation in Afghanistan did
you learn any lessons from that we
learned an enormous number of lessons
from that and those lessons have been
implemented like what kind of things
well the crisis center that is working
seamlessly across government 24 7 since
the crisis broke processing dealing with
everything we are following every single
conceivable opportunity but remember
that Afghanistan was very uh different
and in some way this is worse than that
because we don't have troops on the
ground we don't control the airport like
we did in Afghanistan and we don't have
a permissive environment Khartoum
airport is is not working got no planes
can land or take off and of course
there's not a permissive environment we
had the permission of the Taliban to
leave from Kabul this is a ceasefire and
it can break down and you we're talking
about the British Nationals who can
leave
of course in Sudan there's many other
people who can't leave right because
they live there what are we doing to
help them well there's 16 million people
already who are on humanitarian relief
help with food and also with other
humanitarian support
they that's before this crisis started
and as a result of this crisis the
humanitarian agencies have had to take
their people out five humanitarian
workers have died and so the situation
is even worse it's not just that there's
a greater humanitarian crisis it's that
the humanitarian Community I'm not there
to help them so so that is why having a
ceasefire is absolutely essential and we
know you or someone who believes in
international age you help believe in
helping the poorest people in the world
the most vulnerable people in the world
because obviously it's the right thing
to do to help them but also I guess
there's a soft power there you you would
you can intervene earlier to try and
mean that you can shape the situation if
you like
Aid to Sudan halved recently 142 million
in 2020 to 2021 to 62 million in 21 to
22. these things have consequences don't
they well if you look at the position
over recent years we've spent something
like a quarter of a billion pounds there
in relief but you're looking at the
bilateral figures we we help in a whole
range of different ways through the
United Nations through the various
looking at the foreign
they are the they are the bilateral yes
they are but their aid from the UK to
Saddam yes but remember we support
people of Sudan through humanitarian
relief not only bilaterally but also
through un agencies so so the picture is
uh is is not quite as as those figures
would suggest because there's other
support that we give but but remember
that when there is a humanitarian crisis
we have a degree of flexibility as we've
shown in the Horn of Africa for example
so that we we can do more and I guess my
point is if you intervene earlier with
Aid I mean you believe this too right
you believe this if you intervene early
with Aid people argue that you don't
have to have the same full-blown
humanitarian crises well the
humanitarian crises that occur that they
they can they can be mitigated in some
ways by by the sort of climate change
adaptation money that we spend which
means that the next time the same sort
of Crisis strikes uh then there is
greater resilience but remember this did
not start as a humanitarian crisis it
started because two generals were
slugging it out for control there's no
ideology involved here and there's no
weather conditions involved here it is
broken down because of the behavior of
these two generals but the point I'm
making is this that on a humanitarian
crisis we do have a degree of
flexibility and we exercise that as
crises arrive okay what are the safe and
legal routes for someone in Sudan to
claim asylum in the UK
well at the moment those safe and legal
routes don't exist but the prime
minister in the changes that we are
making as part of the legislation which
is going through the house tonight has
said that we will be seeking to set up
safe and legal routes there's a package
in order to stop the awful uh
cross-channel
um uh trade that has been perpetrated by
The People's Smugglers there's a package
there and it includes developing safe
and legal routes it includes a massive
Improvement in the relationship with the
French and it improves much quicker
processing in the UK so so the the prime
minister's package which we're
legislating for tonight is I think the
right package to deter people from
putting themselves into the hands of the
modern day equivalent of the slave
trader and a leaky boat and crossing the
channel so safe and legal routes to
Sudan will happen no I'm not saying that
what I'm saying is that the government
has made it clear that it will be trying
to as a result of this whole package all
the measures we're taking that we will
be looking to try and make sure the safe
and legal routes are set up I mean we
have no time scale for this we don't
know what countries they're gonna affect
we have no details on it
are you happy with that what well I
think I think there's a there's a it's
important to get it right there's a
there's a longer term plan which the
Prime Minister has uh brought in when he
looked at these the whole issue of the
boats Crossing uh the channel and
migration but to your earlier point I
would just point out that the
development budget International
Development spending which as you say I
do believe strongly and so do so do
millions of people in Britain it is
designed to try and build safer more
prosperous societies and countries over
there so that people don't feel the need
to move to the Richer world
um
I'm voting on the illegal migration Bill
about trying to stop small boats about
um sending people to Rwanda if they do
make that Crossing now the Home
Secretary says she can't say whether
it's compatible with the conventional
and human rights but she wants MPS to
vote for anyway I just want to read out
to you what Sir Jeffrey Cox the
conservative mp uh said he said the
government is in fact asking this house
to give legislative sanction to at least
the possibility that a minister of the
crown will deliberately disobey the
international law obligations of this
country what would you say to your
colleague
well I think that we are testing the
limits of the convention and uh we're
not the first government to do so labor
did it as well on one occasion we're
testing the limits and we must see what
happens as a result of that testing
testing the limits of international law
we are yes we are and the government's
been quite open about that because the
law the law as uh it operates at the
moment and in particular the conventions
uh the migration conventions are quite
dated I think they do need to be updated
but it's a very difficult thing to do
because you have to have uh agreement
across all countries so I do think they
are they are needing to be tested and
that's what the government will be doing
uh so Jeffrey Cox says MPS are being
able to ask to approve quite consciously
and deliberately a deliberate breach of
our obligations under the ech are your
lawmakers
he says you're breaching the law you say
you're testing the limits of the law
well if you look at the response from
Robert generic at the dispatch box he
wouldn't accept that but
what I'm saying to you is that we know
that we are testing the frontiers of the
law here we've been quite open about
that as the government properly should
be it is because circumstances are so
changed since these laws were first
brought in I mean testing testing
Frontiers let's see where it lands
testing the frontiers of the law sounds
like you're doing some like great big
Grand gesture like space exploration or
something when actually other people
would say look let's call a spade a
spade you're breaching the law what Sir
Jeffrey Cox is a very eminent lawyer and
former Minister Robert generic is also a
very eminent lawyer and he does not
agree with sir Jeffrey's analysis so I
can't give you an answer on that legal
argument tonight but I can tell you what
the reason the government is doing this
is to try and resolve an intolerable
situation where people are putting
themselves in leaky boats trying to
cross one of the biggest busiest
shipping lanes in the world it's
extremely dangerous and it's wrong and
we're trying to stop it okay thank you
very much